people online are falling in love with
him
i'm not gonna lie those people include
me
my tinder profile now lists me as a
homosexual the best way i can help now
is if i step aside and let government
get back to governing
andrew cuomo certainly
certainly uh is not looking likely to be
the next president lovegov has resigned
andrew cuomo
doesn't quite admit that he was wrong
doesn't actually say he was sorry for
anything but does say that he will
resign
in the next two weeks
wasting energy on distractions
is the last thing that state government
should be doing
and i cannot be the cause of that
new york tough
means new york loving
and i love new york
and i love you
and everything i have ever done
has been motivated by that love we're
going to pause it right there just as a
general rule in politics
if you are resigning over a sex scandal
you might want to minimize the love talk
the the love talk is not serving your
cause
very well especially when andrew cuomo
does it in this
very bizarre sort of
bulldog-ish cuomo esque way of i love
you i love i love my love made me love
so andrew cuomo goes on and on about the
love thing but then he finally gets to
the point namely he's out
and i would never want to be unhelpful
in any way
and i think that given the circumstances
the best way i can help now
is if i step aside and let government
get back to governing
and therefore that's what i'll do
because i work
for you
and doing the right thing
is doing the right thing for you
because as we say it's not about me
it's about we it's not about me it's
about we okay
i am
i would say 15 surprised that andrew
cuomo actually stepped down
i said it months and months ago when he
was first in trouble for this sex
scandal which was really just an excuse
to get him out after he had lost the
confidence of democrats from the covid
scandal which was just
one of the many scandals that has
plagued his administration and the cuomo
family has dominated new york politics
now for three four decades
andrew cuomo is one of the toughest
politicians out there this guy has
survived much worse than this and so the
reason that he is resigning now is not
because he winked at his secretary or
any of the other things that he's
accused of the reason he's resigning now
is because he is no longer any use to
the democrat establishment during the
lockdowns and the height of 2020 andrew
cuomo was a good foil for donald trump
he was this tough brash new yorker right
he was sort of the the anti-trump but
then now that trump is gone andrew cuomo
doesn't serve any purpose he's actually
a big liability
not just because of he got a little grab
happy with the staffers but because he
killed thousands of elderly new yorkers
and then covered it up from the federal
government when there was a doj
investigation
so
andrew cuomo is out now we can chalk it
up as a win
but i think we would be foolish to
pretend as though this is a major
conservative victory this is the liberal
establishment moving the pieces around
on the table as it sees fit and if
andrew cuomo were still of any use to
them they would they would not have done
that by the way you're not going to hear
any sort of apologies from the many many
people who lauded cuomo and and and
praised him to no end during 2020 and
gave him emmys
and gave him
their devotion and even described
themselves
as quomosexuals like people such as
trevor noah the host of the daily show
the one governor who's crushing it the
most right now is andrew cuomo yes
thanks to his handling his approval
rating has soared to a seven year high
and he's even becoming uh
something of a crush for many people
yeah people online are falling in love
with him
and i'm not gonna lie and those people
include me
my tinder profile now lists me as a
homosexual a cuomo sexual they're all
sorts of
social media influencers just writing
these these odes these these romantic
ballads to andrew cuomo
and what was the reality the reality was
he was the maybe the worst governor in
the country in terms of his handling of
kovid he was one of the worst governors
in in the country in terms of his
handling of his staff notably his female
staff everything we were told about this
guy
totally competent on kovit a hero new
york tough he was a he's a feminist he
stands up for women
all of it turned out to be a lie and we
were told this
by the entertainment establishment guys
like trevor noah we were told this by
the news media establishment for
goodness sakes cuomo's brother hosted a
show on cnn i was gonna say it's a major
show on cnn but no show is a major show
on cnn still it was one of their bigger
shows and he was bringing on andrew
cuomo to to joke about how how he didn't
call his mother enough and then they
yucked it up a little bit and he and he
went into his earnest voice and fredo
said andre you're doing a wonderful job
brother i'm so and he wasn't none of
this was true it was all a lie and now
people
wonder why
none of us trust the media establishment
the scientific establishment the
political establishment
this sort of thing is not just on the
fringes it's not just people like trevor
noah
this sort of thing went all the way up
to the top
joe biden
was lauding andrew cuomo during the
entirety of 2020 while joe biden was
running for president and now that joe
biden is the president even after
the announcement of the resignation even
after the attorney general report
showing that andrew cuomo got very grab
happy even after the doj investigation
of andrew cuomo
joe biden says as governor
cuomo did a hell of a job
one of the democrats
through the years that you spoke with
about infrastructure the most
was andrew cuom who is resigning well
now he's resigning today you had
traveled new york with him when you were
vice president to the launch of the
reconstruction of laguardia he was
someone who supported your campaign
early on no you calling him to resign no
you condemned the alleged behavior but
you're someone who spends a lot of time
with mayors and governors
how would you assess
his 10 and a half years
as governor of the state
in terms of his personal behavior or
what he's done as a governor
but he's done a hell of a job
thought he's done a hell of a job
and uh
i mean both on everything from
access to voting to infrastructure the
whole range of things
that's why it's so sad
i have to say that on one point i do
agree with joe biden here andrew cuomo
did a hell of a job as governor
emphasis here of course is on the word
hell
i was a constituent of andrew cuomo's i
have met andrew cuomo on multiple
occasions i'm a native new yorker
i i was andrew cuomo's waiter once at a
restaurant when i was working at a
restaurant high school i ran into andrew
cuomo during hurricane sandy actually
because my pals and i walked out with
cigars during the hurricane literally
bumped into
governor governor cuomo then
he wasn't the worst governor in the
history of new york but he was pretty
bad he he pushed for
an abortion law that would legalize
abortion up until the moment of birth
a huge liberalization of abortion laws
and when it wasn't enough just that he
did that he then celebrated that by
lighting up the freedom tower in pink
to celebrate this wonderful thing that
he was going to kill a lot more little
baby girls isn't that wonderful isn't
that a win for women
this guy an absolute knuckle dragging
moral idiot
scandal-ridden corrupt
did a hell of a job and
still the liberal establishment even as
they show him the curtains even as they
say buddy time to get off the stage
even still they defend him they are
going softer right now on andrew cuomo
one of the worst if not the worst
governor in the country
than they are on ron desantis
the best governor in the country not
just because he never winked at his
secretary not just because he never got
grab happy with the staff but because he
did better on coronavirus than any other
governor in the country and he pursued
the opposite policies then we saw from
certainly from andrew cuomo or from
gavin newsom or anyone else
and yet still
cuomo gets the pat on the head and
desantis does not
i'm glad you liked that clip we got a
whole episode it's called sleazy
democrat gives the kiss of death you can
get it on youtube but you can also get
it at apple podcasts spotify google play
and stitcher head on over there right
now and subscribe to the michael knowles
show i'll wait
thanks for subscribing we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you